[Musique]
arrête les cercles c'est pas une lampe
magique Titanic moi quoi Titanic moi non
mais sérieux c'est trop la
honte lève mes bras j'ai vu le film
vraiment tu veux dire la réplique c'est
je suis le roi du monde tu es le roi du
monde je
VO je crois que j'ai jamais rien vu d'I
chou il rejoue
titanicor
ouais tu penses qu'ils y
croi salut tu vas au mariage de ma sœur
en effet il est où ton fiancé oh c'est
lui tu es vraiment un gamin moi c'est
ben j'ai été son coup d'un soir pendant
votre séparation de quoi tu me
parles je sortirai jamais avec un mec
comme lui cette fille c'est un
boulet ils vont gâcher notre mariage
[Musique]
désolé
V mon Jonathan pouronetteem il est comme
un FS pour
nous tout
leeés mon petit problèmeident que tu k
margar
te voit avec moi voudra
récupérz
fait on Arve
[Musique]
AR que vous devez penser qu'il est trop
vieux pour moi vous pensez pas ça vous
me donnez quoi 27 28 ans à tout
[Musique]
casser personne n'y croit faut qu'on ait
l'air plus proche permission de poser ma
main sur tes fesses
accordé ok arrête les cercles c'est pas
une lampe magique elle ne regarde ça
marche ah non je le crois pas attends je
sens un truc
bizarre oh merde merde où est-ce que j'
est elle est sur toi non c'est bon
c'était une meilleure façon de vérifier
que la
mienne ils sont partis le spectacle est
terminé oh
non oh mon Dieu ils y sont allés à fond
dans le délire Titanic vous avez assuré
les
gars